let's bring in our panel early tonight
harold ford jr former tennessee
congressman ceo of empowerment inclusion
capital
molly hemingway senior editor at the
federalist and trey gowdy former
congressman from south carolina
molly as you look at the potential of
what's already signed and what's
proposed
you have the american rescue plan at 1.9
trillion dollars american jobs plan 2.65
trillion dollars american families plan
1.8
trillion dollars there you have 6.35
trillion with a t that would potentially
if past
go out in an environment where the
economy seems to be
picking up steam thoughts on tonight's
speech
and when you give a state of the union
or an address like this it's
frequently something that politicians
will lie or they'll exaggerate but
they're somewhat constrained by the
facts on the ground
and even 100 days in joe biden doesn't
really have a great set of facts for
tonight i just rewatched
president trump's speech last year that
was a speech that was very optimistic
that talked about the blue collar boom
wage growth for african americans young
people women
energy independents factories coming
back foreign policy successes you know
people thought
trump was going to lead to nuclear
annihilation instead peace was breaking
out all over and we were
conquering our enemies the strike on
suleimani and
baghdadi and just a general optimism
about america america being back for
average people not for dc not for the
media elite but for average people
it almost seems like it came from a
different country just a hundred days in
joe biden has had embarrassing foreign
policy gaps like what were just
referenced with china with russia
with iran you know he he continued
president trump's
warp speed but didn't really you know
we're still having children not in
school
the economy for people who are average
americans is not doing
well uh you know it's doing fine if
you're elite and he's proposing
some real economy crushing ideas in
terms of dragging the economy down
so unless he's using a completely
alternate set of facts he's somewhat
constrained by the
you know just the bad news that we have
in the country right now harold
years ago bill clinton gave a state of
the union address
i believe it was 1996 and said the era
of big government
is over that would not be fitting to
what this speech is tonight
and it may be kicking up again the era
of big government
is back well thanks for having me the
era of smart and big government needs to
come back
uh i think every president when giving
uh
and we'll say she one day when he gives
a state of the union has to be positive
has to lay out a vision and here's where
we are
infection rates hospitalization rates
death rates are down
vaccinations are at 3 million a day
we're going to be able to reopen our
economy
sure there's a little friction there's
old tension in the system with
conspiracy theorists and others making
arguments but we are making progress
as we move forward we have to ensure
that we are prepared for anything that
comes our way i think this president's
going to lay out a plan whether it's
china or
new covet the investments he's choosing
and intending to make
will enable us to get past the mindless
tribal politics
and find a path that not only unleashes
the ability to create bipartisan
solutions
but ensures that we can compete and win
against any foe
be it china or new cobot that's what i
look to here tonight that's true
anticipate hearing tonight harold talks
about mindless tribal politics
but there's politics here and democrats
have so far been able to herd the cats
and stay on one
page as far as how the administration
sees it and what they want to get done
quickly washington post ashley parker
writes so far republicans have struggled
in their attempts
to vilify president biden or paint him
as out of touch big government socialist
a move by senator ted cruz to depict
biden as boring but radical
fell flat so are republicans able to
sing from the same sheet of music here
in response
uh you you wouldn't think so based on
the reporting coming out of their
retreat
in florida but but but republicans
should should take hope for this reason
i mean joe biden is doing what they tell
you to do in politics which is talk
reasonably
but actually legislate and govern as a
progressive
but he talks reasonably the net result
is going to be
he may be fine in two years but because
of court packing
and because of this social
infrastructure and because of
other initiatives hr1 he's going to lose
the house
so congratulations people really like
you but they don't like the house and
you're going to lose the house and
whatever you want to do you're not going
to be able to do for the remainder of
your time in president
that's the trade-off he has molly we
mentioned tim scott in his response a
couple
excerpts just here's another one just
before covet we had the most inclusive
economy in my lifetime
that happened because republicans
focused on expanding opportunity for all
americans
we passed opportunity zones criminal
justice reform
permanent funding for historically black
colleges and universities for the first
time ever
we fought the drug academic rebuilt our
military cut taxes for working families
and single moms like mine
he says our best future won't come from
washington schemes
or socialist dreams it will come from
you the american people
it's often tough to do a response to any
state of the union or joint address
tonight's a little different in the
covid situation
but that's part of the message he'll
he'll give
it's tough but tim scott is someone that
people are very interested in i think
they're excited to hear from him
and it kind of relates to what i was
saying he has the benefit of good facts
when the republicans were running things
or when trump was running things
things were doing very well contrary to
what the media claim about joe biden
he's actually
more divisive statistically speaking
than even donald trump was
he's a polarizing figure his agenda has
been radical
or as cnn called it radical moderation
or something like that
moderate radicalism uh it's not popular
with the american people there are
crises on the border
there's this profligate spending you
know he thinks the country is a racist
dystopic hell hole
people don't like to hear about this and
he's governing as if he had majorities
that he clearly doesn't have
and this is a problem in the real world
even if the media are doing as much to
help him as they did to tear down donald
trump
quickly harold i doubt we will hear the
three words racist dystopic hellhole but
in this speech you think it's going to
be an optimistic tone going forward
joe biden's entire political career has
been predicated on bringing
people together finding compromise some
will argue that the first bill the
coveted relief bill was something he did
alone with just democrats and that's
probably right
he campaigned on that this the the next
phase of his presidency trey is right
the next phase of his presidency is
going to depend heavily on finding
compromise and what
better rebuttal for the white house than
to have tim scott an honorable decent
person who's ready to help lead
on police accountability reform i look
forward to both of their speeches
tonight